rasender stillstand sei das was wir
erleben in unserer welt die sich
beschleunigt dass die festplatten blühen
und uns die mails noch mitternachts um
die ohren fliegen das sagen zwei von
deutschlands bekanntesten scharf denkern
rüdiger safranski der philosophierende
schriftsteller holt dabei wunderbar weit
aus und taucht in seinem neuen buch über
die zeit existenzielle und
philosophische erkenntnisse herauf vom
wesen der langeweile bis zu unserem
wunsch nach ewigkeit und dem tiefen
wieder werden das leben loszulassen
der wein hartmut rosa einer der
führenden zeit soziologen ungewöhnlich
scharf warnt vor beschleunigungs
totalitarismus der uns individuell mit
totaler entfremdung bedrohe und erst
noch die demokratie in unserer modernen
gesellschaft kaputt schlagen können
bevor wir über beschleunigte
lebensspanne und die ewigkeit treten
sehr punktuell und sehr persönlich
gefragt herr safranski was war der
schönste augenblick in ihrem leben
schwer zu sagen
privat was als sie mich das dritte mal
verliebt das war ein ganz toller moment
und das hält ja auch immer alles noch
vor und der andere große moment war
wirklich da war ich in berlin als die
mauer fiel das war unser persönlichen
vita hat ja eher aus ist natürlich eine
unglaubliche zb sport also es waren
augenblicke die irgendwie andauern bis
heute na ja die bilder dass ich meine so
ist es ja mit den großen augen blicken
die sind dann ganz gegenwärtig ja und
deswegen sind das dann auch groß und so
zeichnen die sich aus dass sie bleiben
und rosa der schönste augenblick ist
schwierig zu sagen aber mir würde einer
anfallen der sich gar nicht weit von
hier ereignet hat nämlich im
hallenstadion in zürich weil ich war als
jugendlicher totaler pink floyd fans
ich konnte von der ball der den gesamten
text auswendig und habe die platte mit
mitgesungen und hat auch alle bücher von
pink floyd gelesen und dann war roger
waters der hier die wesentlichen
geschrieben hat tatsächlich auf tournee
mit eric clapton damals und das war mein
erstes großes konzert
und ich erinnere mich immer noch daran
was ist was das bedeutete als dann das
saallicht dunkel wird und es wird leise
uns kommen geheimnis
tolle töne und es schlägt dann um in
gleißendes licht und volle lautstärke
und dann stehen die wirklich vor allem
auf der bühne steht das hat sowas von
epiphanie dass mir ganz tief dass mich
ganz tief beeindruckt hat ich frage das
um ein bisschen abzustecken wonach wir
hier suchen sollen jetzt in unserem
gespräch weil ihnen beiden büchern
schreiben sie
es geht um die suche nach dem guten
leben und da ist die frage besteht das
gute leben aus ein paar ganz starken
eigenen augen blicken letztlich oder ist
noch etwas anderes wichtig so ein langer
großflächiger guter grundton im leben
hat hans jaich wenn man so unterscheidet
dann würde ich sagen in der hauptsache
besteht dann doch aus einem gelingenden
rhythmus des lebens also nicht die
lichter lohn augenblicke die sind
wunderbar aber ob insgesamt es der tag
des lebens stimmt das ist glaube ich ein
ganz entscheidend und da waren sie beide
toll geschriebenen büchern davor dass
wir in der gesellschaft jetzt im begriff
sind oder in einem rasenden stillstand
uns herum schleudern lassen der aber
nicht viel bringt in sachen glück für
das einzelne leben
rosas kommt mir ein bisschen so vor wie
im lied von helene fischer glaube ich
atemlos durch die nacht aber heute ist
auch atemlos durch den tag alles durch
die arbeitswelt ist die atemlosigkeit
das problem ja ich glaube auf der sollte
das objekte schlägt sich das genau darin
nieder dass menschen immer das gefühl
haben schon zu spät dran zu sein immer
zu wenig salz haben und schneller machen
zu müssen als sie es von natur aus oder
von ihrer gewohnheit austreten insofern
glaube ich kann man schon sagen wir
leben in einer atemlosen zeit ja und das
findet sie ziemlich schlimm ja also ich
kenne ich finde ich finde
geschwindigkeit nicht per se schlimm
aber wenn sie zu einem dauerzustand wird
wenn sie unsere unseren habitus die art
und weise wie wir im leben stehen und
wie wir den menschen und den dingen
begegnen so verändert dass es zu einem
zustand der entfremdung für dann finden
schlimm als soziologe gibt der
gesellschaft gerade in oberbegriffen
beschleunigungs gesellschafts
risikogesellschaft erlebnisse hat er da
recht ist dass das hauptmerkmal unsere
gesellschaft beschleunigungs
gesellschaft naja ich denke ja hat eine
wirklich sehr präzise analyse des
gesellschaftlichen getriebes jahr
vorgelegt wozu natürlich auch gehört
diese paradoxie das dass man einerseits
ja auch immer mehr zeit gewinnt durch
beschleunigte reisen durch durch
beschleunigt beschleunigung formen der
tätigkeit aber man gewinnt offenbar auch
immer mehr zeit um die totzuschlagen
also wir sind ja auch eine eine
gesellschaft der unterhaltung ja das ist
ja auch ein riesen riesen sektor man hat
dann schon wenn man mal so eine
draufsicht macht hat bei den eindruck
die gesellschaft produziert auch immer
mehr zeit in der nichts geschehen würde
wenn nicht unterhaltung bisher ja
unterhalten wird unterhalten werden
müssen ja die absturzgefährdeten ja da
wir nicht man muss man gehalten werden
ich glaube es gibt von von dem großen
pascal schon ja etwas verrät pascal dem
mathematiker und philosoph in der frühen
neuzeit
der hatte schon die these aufgestellt
damals dass sich sehr sehr vieles in der
gesellschaft einfach nur erklärt daher
dass die menschen auf der flucht sind
vor der langeweile oder man könnte auch
sagen vor dem schwarzen loch in das sie
selber fallen könnten
und das in ihnen selbst lauert also ich
will sagen wir haben wir leben in einer
beschleunigungs gesellschaft wir leben
aber auch in einer zeit vertreibung
gesellschaft das ist auch interessant
genau und bei pascal bleibt der satz war
alles unheil rührt daher dass die
menschen nicht zu hause bleiben will ich
ein bisschen noch wissen wie sie in
dieser gesellschaft und arbeit
gesellschaft stehen
man sagen bei ihnen als professor sie
sind halt in dem hamsterrad drin mit
terminen rektorats verpflichtungen sind
sie voll eingespannt und ein opfer
dieses rasenden stillstands ja ich
glaube schon also ist es nicht so dass
ich mich diesen zwängen längst zu
bereden entzogen hätte bloß weil ich
dieses phänomen analysiere ist es eher
umgekehrt man kann es im gegenwärtigen
hochschulen und forschungsbetrieb ganz
gut analysieren wenn man sieht wie
solche zwänge so zustande kommen dass es
ganz ganz schwer wird sich ihnen auch
als als als aufgeklärt das individuum zu
entziehen
sie wirken recht locker und fast
glücklich leiden sie darunter
ja ist es so eine mischung ja ich glaube
ich leide man darunter jedenfalls
manchmal natürlich genieße ich es auch
ich glaube schon also gefragt zu sein
schnell unterwegs zu sein beweglich und
dynamisch zu sein hat immer auch an
seine befriedigung ja das ist so ein
kick und das hängt mit unserer
vorstellung von freiheit zusammen und
davon
selbstwirksamkeit und trotzdem leidet
man darunter und malweise dann an diesem
leiden zu arbeiten das abzuarbeiten ist
dann eben das zu analysieren und darüber
zu schreiben ein anderer geht es um
psychiater soziologisch schreibt das
nächste setzt mich an schreibtisch ich
gute strategie herr safranski sind sie
das gegenmodell der freie schriftsteller
der sich allem entziehen kann von diesen
unangenehmen zeit zwingen
naja natürlich nicht alle aber ich sag
schon dass ich meinen fall nicht so
einfach verallgemeinern kann ich bin
tatsächlich in keinem angestellten
keinen beamtenverhältnis ich bin der
unternehmer meiner selbst ja ich kann
doch in einem hohen maße habe ich schon
noch zeitsouveränität ich kann mir das
selber einteilen ich kann mir auch bis
hin zum alltäglichen rhythmus allerdings
erfahre ich natürlich auch diesen
wechsel also wenn man jetzt ein buch
geschrieben hat dann dann kommt dann
mindestens ein halbes jahr oder sammer
vier monate so ungefähr wo man dann
natürlich voll im geschirr ist also da
da erlebe ich natürlich dann auch die
andere seite und die ist wenn sie so
wollen natürlich hoch beschleunigt da
ist man da und da an da und springt über
als nomade
reist seinem buch gewissermaßen
hinterher als nomade als ja also da
merke ich es schon was das bedeutet aber
dann will ich auch sagen finde ich dass
dem weg da sind wir wieder beim rhythmus
den wechsel finde ich eben schön man
zieht sich zurück und heckt was aus ja
so ist das dann bei mir und dann geht
man die rampe und da gilt auf einmal
eine andere in der galt eine andere
geschwindigkeit
man hat seine geschwindigkeit wenn man
ein buch schreibt er oder werde man aber
sammelt und man hat eine andere
geschwindigkeit wenn man es gibt in den
tumult geht also den totalen rückzug aus
der zeit predigt dir keiner am tisch
wenn ich recht dass heraus höre aber in
den ruhigen zeiten wie machen sie das
also sind sie an diszipliniert aber sie
auch bis 12 26 oder wie geht das bald da
bin ich sehr bin ich sehr diszipliniert
weil ich eben auch merken wenn dieses
oder man könnte auch sagen ritual ich
mache einen 1 3 1 ein ritual dann geht
das wirklich morgens los nachdem
zeitungsläden und müssen die mittagszeit
und dann eine pause und dann noch mal so
zwei drei stunden und dann spazieren
gehen und dann verbringe ich mit meiner
frau und freunden und so weit in den
abend und machte auch wirklich darauf
dass dann der gryphon hingelegt wird
oder die der der pc ausgestellt wird
man muss ja das gehört ja auch zur zeit
man muss schon durch dieses ritual
herausbekommen welches die guten momente
sind ja das gehört ja auch zur klugheit
in bezug auf umgehen mit der zeit muss
die besten momente erwischen der der
große schopenhauer der der sagte ja
eigentlich richtig hell wach ist man nur
die ersten zwei stunden morgens ja und
dann fügte dann auf seine bissige art
gleich hinzu und so viel unsinn wird
geschmiert sagt er weil die leute nicht
akzeptieren dass sie nur die zwei wochen
zwei stunden richtig und 18 uhr oder
hailfingen hätten dann aber hegel zum
beispiel hat viel zu lange geschrieben
der sich ziemlich persönlich
wahrscheinlich schreiben nicht sie einer
von ihnen irgendwo ein nachtmensch und
ein tag mensch die die leben in
verschiedenen universen das persönliche
obama gut dass am morgen oder am haben
ja das ist ich denke das hängt mit der
wir das ist ja das muss mal auf bekommen
wie der eigene rhythmus bei mir ist
eindeutig morgens ja wenn also professor
rosa hier über entfremdung schreibt sie
kein typisches opfer davon weil sie ein
glücklicher schriftsteller sind aber die
gesellschaft als ganzes das besorgt sie
schon die hat sich ergreifen lassen von
diesem beschleunigungs totalitarismus
seit wann zieht das so richtig an
also ich glaube das ist ein langer
prozess ist also ist es bestimmt ein
irrtum wenn wir versuchen unsere
heutigen zeit strukturen und muster zu
verstehen dann erst im zeitalter der
digitalisierung zu beginnen das heißt
ich glaube das macht seit dem
achtzehnten jahrhundert sich wirklich
unsere zeit orientierung auch in dort da
hat man ja oft vermutet dass die technik
die ursache dafür sein konnte als dann
die eisenbahn oder dampfschiffe
eingeführt worden
aber ich glaube dass es umgekehrt ist
eisenbahn und dampfschiffe sind schon
eine antwort auf ein verändertes zeit
bewusst sein die die idee zeit zu
bewirtschaften und auch einfach die idee
dass zeit knapp ist ist vorgängig und
dann zieht sie sich da eigentlich durch
also seitdem seine turbinen sozial den
sozial wirbelwind
entdeckt hat oder marx und engels davor
warnen dass alles ständig und stehende
zum verdampfen gebracht wird haben
eigentlich kulturelle selbst
beobachtungen immer dieses knapp werden
von zeit dieses rasche vergehen von zeit
zum thema gehabt aber ich denke schon
dass das alles weil sie danach gefragt
ob man anzieht das als seit 1990 da noch
mal eine deutliche
geschwindigkeitserhöhung also eine
beschleunigung welle auf uns zukommen
das hat mit dem internet dann genau also
das hat mindestens drei ursachen
wahrscheinlich also erstens der fall der
mauer da wirklich die mauer war ja fast
auch war wirklich ein physisches
bewegungs hemmnis das hat eine rolle
gespielt aber dann natürlich auch die
digital so digitalisierungsprozess aber
auch die die globalisierung der
finanzmärkte zum beispiel eine
veränderung im produktions regime was
häufiger als post fort ismus beschrieben
wird just in time produktion und
insbesondere internet und
digitalisierung die haben das tempo
nochmal deutlich erhöht und das fühlen
wir heute in allen möglichen varianten
rüdiger safranski sie haben das auch
ziemlich in die tiefe untersucht wann
die echtzeit in die weltgeschichte daher
ein geplatzt ist ein ganz tolle passage
fand ich als sie beschreiben wie
schiller einen großen historischen
moment verpasst hat ja also ich meine
das ist für mich auch eine eine ganz
ganz große zäsur dass wir jetzt erst
jetzt erst das heißt also sagen wir mal
so ab 1900 seitdem wir telekommunikation
haben und und eine eine
kommunikationsmöglichkeit haben die in
echtzeit gleichzeitigkeit herstellt
zwischenraum entfernten punkten
so etwas hat es menschheitsgeschichte
ich noch nie gegeben das ist eine so
ungeheure neue konstellation die da auf
einmal auftaucht ja was jetzt mit dem
schiller erwähnen
gerade der der
ist von den nachrichten der
französischen revolution beunruhigt und
denkt es läuft auf eine hinrichtung des
königs zu in frankreich und das findet
der furchtbar und deswegen setzt er sich
hin und wird schon mal eine rede wo er
den franzosen ins gewissen reden will er
will auch rüber fahren und dann den
hilfen nicht nachgelassen ist schon eher
schon längst enthauptet das heißt das
ist natürlich in einer welt die diese
gleichzeitigkeit nicht hat da muss man
sich klar machen ist im grunde alles ist
gleichzeitig nur was der unmittelbare
sinnen kreis und land kann und der rest
der welt der riesengroße rest der welt
ist immer in der im modus der
vergangenheit eigentlich präsent es ist
immer alles schon längst geschehen wenn
es bei mir ankommt das hat neben chile
hat das eine eine gravierende folge man
kann man konnte gar nicht auf die idee
kommen dass man für die ganze welt mit
verantwortlich ist wirklich das lokale
hahn lebt in der glocke seiner eigenen
zeit ja so richtig und da war das das
heißt dass es da wirklich echte
handlungsmöglichkeiten gibt in einem
direkt in einem spontan verhältnis dass
das war sowieso so da war war das war
unmöglich aber schilder hätte doch
applaudiert wenn das internet oder
mindestens ein radiogerät gekommen wäre
gar nicht idealisiert ja würde sagen
also umgekehrt natürlich die die hätten
wenn die das gehört hätten was bei uns
möglich ist gerade so jemand wie fehler
der hätte das natürlich großartig
befunden oder so jemand wie forster oder
oder dieser diese leute die unglaubliche
welt gierig welt neugierig waren und so
weiter aber man muss auch sagen dass es
das natürlich eine eine situation
schafft wo eigentlich eine
latente panik sicherlich die emotionale
entsprechung dazu ist wenn wenn wenn
wenn man so sehr von gleichzeitigkeit
belagert wird global das ist eigentlich
erst die globale globalisierung
das ist auf jeden fall die
herausforderung unseres ganzen
gefühlshaushalt weil so eine permanente
unrast dann herr natürlich und
verantwortung und sollte was tut man
kann nichts tun okay von daher aber
obwohl sie wissen in den medien dann als
der chef entschleuniger gehandelt worden
der sie glaube ich gar nicht sein wollen
eben ganz zurück in eine zeit wo nur
kleine welten im nachhinein voneinander
erfahren hat schon auch was tolles diese
diese echt zeitung gleichzeitig auf
jeden fall als man das in nostalgische
sehnsüchte wenn wir zu anderen
ergebnissen kommen die wir dann zurück
projizieren also das zeigt dass zeit
bewusstsein anderer kulturen können wir
sowieso glaube ich gar nicht wirklich
nachempfinden und nostalgische
verklärung helfen können also ich glaube
nicht dass es das ziel sein könnte die
welt so langsam zu machen dass diese
echtzeit verbindungen wieder zerfallen
sie sagen man kann sich das nicht
vorstellen wie die zeit empfunden haben
gibt auch eine stelle die mir gefallen
hat in ihrem buch wie brust seinen
ersten telefon der schriftsteller der
über die verlorene zeit ja das
vielleicht wichtigste bekannteste buch
geschrieben hat sein erstes
telefongespräch das ein totaler schock
damals na ja und auch keine ganz grosse
verzauberung ja das war ja für mich so
wie der platz auch schildert das ist ja
fast wie eine stimme aus dem hd sehen
hat er schon wieder angerufen ja ja wen
hat dann der er hatte die großmutter
hatte angerufen der dem ersten moment
denkt er jetzt tot die jetzt die ihre
stimme kommt dass die klingt von der
ferne wir kennen das ja noch ein
bisschen am anfang das will also ich
weiß nach unserer kindheit wenn die
leute da telefoniert haben ja dann haben
wir immer reingerufen ins telefon
so als müssten sie die distanz noch
durch lautstärke ein bisschen mit
überwinden besonders wenn man ein
übersee
brechen das war natürlich ganz ganz gut
aber ich wollte noch mal zu der
vergangenheit sagen
also ich wirklich kein grund jetzt nur
style geschichte zurück zu träumen aber
umgekehrt mich macht das immer wenn man
in die vergangenheit geht also ein thema
zum beispiel gleichzeitigkeit wenn man
sich vollmer klar macht dass die diese
gleichzeitigkeit nicht hat hatten dann
erst begreift man das ungeheuerliche der
moderne
also man muss gewissermaßen diesen
befremdung schritt machen um auf einmal
zu merken was für uns nämlich schon ganz
alltäglich ist dass das eigentlich eine
ungeheuerlichkeit ist und dazu hilft
dieser historisierende blick das
gegenwärtige erscheint erscheint auf
einmal in einem neuen licht
ich glaub ich glaube das wäre dass
solche versuche sind wirklich ganz
wichtig und dann sehen wir dass wir uns
häufig auch täuschen
ich glaube gerade beim umgang mit zeit
gibt es eine art von von illusion weil
wir immer denken mehr zeitsouveränität
würde mehr freiheit bringen und welche
rat wenn man sich anguckt dass man denkt
na ja wer selbstbestimmt über seine zeit
verfügt der hat eine gelassenheit ja der
hat nicht dieses gefühl des gesteins
aber erstaunlicherweise stimmt das nicht
so eins zu eins wenn man eine
bauernfamilie betrachtet diese
tatsächlich auch heute noch gibt gerade
in der scheiße bergbauernfamilie oder so
die hat natürlich überhaupt keine selbst
bestimmte zeit oder fast keine ddr ahnte
diesen komplett getaktet durch die
rhythmen der natur das vieh muss
versorgt werden morgens und abends ist
muss gesät und geerntet werden wie es
die natur vorgibt und die menschen
können dann wirklich nicht mal eine
woche weg oder zwei wochen weg trotzdem
hat man das gefühl die stehen ganz
anders in der zeit ja die haben nicht
diese die haben nicht diese steigerung
orientierung dieses vielleicht fehlt da
auch im moment von dieser
gleichzeitigkeit von der sie schreiben
es gibt da weil sie gebunden sind nicht
diese tausend andere dinge die man von
ihnen erwarten kann oder wie sie selber
erwarten und das wird zu einem ganz
anderen in der zeit seien also nicht
diese idealisierung die wir auch von den
indianern machten die irgendwie einfach
glücklich in der natur ständen die natur
allein machen jetzt macht's nicht da ja
aber der hinweis ist natürlich schon
sehr gut jetzt mit dem bauern wir uns
das auch immer noch gibt ja das ist ja
etwas so eine art
tätigkeit von der natur ahlen zeit auch
von diesen zeit rhythmen ja und das
macht natürlich schon ein unterschied ob
man von dem natural rhythmus
zeitrhythmus abhängig ist oder vom
zeitlichen rhythmus eines lieben
mitmenschen der einem da was auf
herrscht ja der schon anfängt zu meckern
wenn man eine mail nicht sofort
beantworten und ja also da jemand diese
art von fan von abhängigkeit ist alles
ist eine andere
na ja da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher
ob es wirklich dass die entscheidende
differenz
sie haben recht also die natur in der
natur rhythmen sind deshalb irgendwie
sozusagen erstmal harmlose weil man eben
nichts dran ändern kann an sozial
rothmann kameras ändern aber natürlich
hat man sich andere gesellschaftsformen
und kulturen ansieht die hatten soziale
rhythmen in vielerlei hinsicht die waren
immer auch abhängig von der tour wieder
gab es auch sozial
aber die hatten nicht diese idee dass
man da permanent innovation steigerung
optimierung und zeitersparnis ins spiel
bringen müsste also ich glaube man
könnte auch soziale rhythmen haben und
gestalten ohne in diesen steigerungs
modus zu kommen jetzt hat er gesagt es
wäre nicht die technik gewesen die den
wechsel gebracht hat ist aber eine
beliebte these das ist doch zum beispiel
die eisenbahn war die die
gleichzeitigkeit erzwungen hat naja ich
denke die dachten vorher werden ja
sicher dass auch sehen dass natürlich
die die alten bahn hat dann noch mal im
großen stil so einen schub auch übrigens
für die synchronisierung für die
gleichzeitigkeit das also jeder ob jetzt
an eine zentral zeit angeschlagen dafür
hat das natürlich auch aber der hinweis
ist natürlich solche es gibt zugleich
immer auch solche tiefen prozesse in der
auch an der mentalität die sich so
langsam vollziehen
ich würde im übrigen für für diesen
schub der der der der zeitlichen
beschleunigung auch die geburt des
kreditsystems mit als ein ganz ganz
wichtigen punkt dafür in der frühen
neuzeit der wenn es dann
immer im großen stil also los geht jetzt
die kredite zu gewähren fristen müssen
dann eingehalten werden jetzt man muss
das irgendwie produktiv umgesetzt werden
das heißt es wird durch auch durch ein
ein wirtschaftssystem
wir nennen das dann den frühkapitalismus
ja wird wird wird die zeit organisation
und die die immanenten befristen mit
denen mit denen jetzt hier agiert wird
auch im medium der konkurrenz ja
schneller zu sein als de als schneller
zu verwerten schneller umzusetzen
kredite rechtzeitig zu bedienen und so
weiter da entsteht ein für die gratis
netz von zeitlichen organisationen die
insgesamt natürlich eine dynamik los
treten und da passt dann natürlich dass
jetzt die technik neue mittel bringt die
das alles nochmal potenzieren ist also
so ein wechsel so eine wechselwirkung ja
dass ich auch so sehen also die technik
ermöglicht diese diese permanenten
steigerungen aber das neue im
achtzehnten jahrhundert wo ich eben
glaube dass man die zeit nicht isoliert
betrachten darf ist diese steigerung
orientierung die von der ich glaube die
ist nicht einfach nur eine kulturelle
also weil wir anders drauf sind oder
andere kulturelle ideen adaptiert haben
sondern ist eine institutionelle und
strukturellen der moderne gesellschaft
der kapitalistische gesellschaft kann
sich nur erhalten und reproduzieren in
ihrer struktur durch steigerung also
beim wirtschaftssystem sieht man das
sehr deutlich
ohne wachstum und wachstum wird erzählt
über beschleunigung und permanente
innovations- verdichtung und ohne diese
steigerung momente können wir nicht so
bleiben wie wir sind verlieren wir
arbeitsplätze schließen die firmen
können wir die kredite nicht
zurückzahlen so dass natürlich
systematisch sieht über das kreditwesen
aber auch über viele andere dinge
der zwang zur steigerung ist strukturell
anders und kann dieses jahr eine tolle
weg der auf die zukunft dass alles
besser wird sonst würde man da ja und
das ist auch ein punkt also da ich auch
wieder sowas nochmal wo man zum staunen
angeregt wird wenn man dann in
vergangenheiten blick im mittelalter
ja kann man sagen war es
selbstverständlich dass man beim alten
blick und das neue war
begründungspflicht ich und irgendwann
mal dreht sich im gigantischen maße
langsam die bühne und wir haben
natürlich jetzt die situation
das neue ist garnicht begründungspflicht
ich begründungspflicht ich ist wenn du
beim alten altera und jetzt da ich meine
dann muss man sich mal hinein denken was
das für ein denken war dann im
mittelalter noch ja das eigentlich die
welt etwas ziemlich unveränderliches ist
völlig verändert sich ja vieles und so
weiter aber das ist eigentlich ziemlich
unerheblich ja sondern sie war so und
das war die das diesseits und dann gab
es natürlich eine riesengroße
veränderung das war das jenseits
gewissermaßen alle veränderungen im
mittelalterlichen denken ist ausgelagert
ins jenseits und das diesseits steht
unter stabilitäts gesichtspunkt dass
bleibt eigentlich so ist und jede
originelle leistung ja auch bei den
autoren im mittelalter ja die taten
immer so als seien sie das nicht sondern
die namen dem oft in einen namen an
eines alten jahr dann wurde dem augustin
noch vieles untergeschoben ja und so
weiter du hast ja gar nicht geschrieben
also originalität war nicht gefragt wer
hat diese bombe der zukunfts offenheit
in die welt geistesgeschichte
hineingeworfen weiß man das also ist
also ich bin ziemlich sicher dass man
das nicht einer person zu rechnen kann
dass es ein zusammenfließen von ganz
vielen momenten bei denen solche
strukturellen der ökonomische
veränderungen ein kapitalistisches
system hat ein anderes konzept von
zeitlichkeit die spielen da eine rolle
aber zum beispiel natürlich auch der
westfälische friede sozusagen das die
konkurrenz unter dem staaten system
gespielt da glaube ich eine große rolle
also konkurrenz ist ein moment was
dynamisierung in
ins spiel bringt und damit einhergehen
um orientierungen glaube ich in allen
lebensbereichen selbst im
wissenschaftsbetrieb also ich finde es
wirklich interessant zu sehen dass diese
veränderung diese beschreiben man auch
an der art wie wir mit wissen umgehen
sehen kann wissen ist wie lange zeit
hinweg gewesen also der welt die sie
gerade beschrieben haben so was wie
einen schatz den man hütet und
weitergibt und allenfalls mal minimal
vielleicht noch in der rückprojektion
verändert und der ema meter bibel
kompatibel sein muss denn mit der bibel
oder mit einer tot ist aber jedenfalls
mit irgendwelchen altehrwürdigen quellen
und dieser moderne begriff der
wissenschaft dafür hat man geradezu den
wandel hat das was permanent neu
geschaffen wird was die grenzen
erweitert und voranschreitet also ich
glaube es waren wirklich ideale momente
kulturelle momente und aber auch
ökonomische und politische momente die
so zusammengeschlossen sind das die sich
gegenseitig jeweils bestellten in den
beschleunigung streep es hängt natürlich
schon würde ich mal sagen würden der
tiefen die struktur auch damit zusammen
dass das die trends transzendenz
religiösen sinne mehr und mehr verloren
gingen und in diesem moment hat man also
wenn wenn nicht mehr klar ist dass man
eigentlich nur zwei grund wege hat
entweder geht der weg zur erlösung oder
kälte die hölle ja so will man dieses
beiden grund oder vielleicht noch
fegefeuer noch dazwischen ja wenn man
nicht mehr diese optionen insgesamt hat
ja sondern jetzt auf einmal
der himmel ist leer und jetzt öffnet
sich dann wird dieser raum jetzt auch
eher der sinn raum den musst du jetzt
selber fühlen denn den durch ja da kommt
es natürlich die quote ein anderer modus
der bewegung jetzt auf einmal wird es
entscheiden ja vielleicht der erste
konnte dann kommen konkurrenzen dann
musste der erste sein dann investiert
mal ins produkt nicht in den sinn
sondern ins produkt und so weiter also
dass ich glaube also die
es gibt ja diesen schönen ausdruck der
metaphysischen obdachlosigkeit die
metaphysische obdachlosigkeit erzeugt
eine ganz neues umgehen mit der zeit da
wird es auch einmal ganz wichtig was da
wird der fortschritt ganz wichtig wenn
das jenseits nicht mehr gibt wird der
ford und da müssen wir hin was machen
und ich voll gehen gerne wenn sie sagen
das war so nicht die technik wie gewisse
technik historiker sagen oder die leute
die glauben dass der fortschritt ohnehin
von neuer besserer technik abhängig
aber ich will kurz darauf kommen dass
die dieser fortschritt der technische
dann wie auf widerstand traf in der
gesellschaft zum beispiel die eisenbahn
weiß man ja die leute hatten angst ab 30
stundenkilometern würde man ersticken
krank werden nie mehr aus einer gruppe
heraus kommen und da habe ich mich
gefragt als ich ihr warnendes buch
gelesen aber sie sagen dass schleudert
uns herum und ist nicht mehr schön in
der arbeitszeit könnte es nicht auch
sein dass wir die leute sind die vor der
eisenbahn warnen und sagen 30 km h sind
zu viel
während dem unsere kinder und neffen und
enkeln sagen ob das geht auch schneller
doch also ich darüber erst also diese
frage muss man sich immer wieder stellen
ich frage mich manchmal auch ob ich
nicht schon gegen die einführung der
schrift gewesen wäre mit dem argument
das ist viel schöner als wenn wir uns
vorsetzen und uns geschichten erzählen
also wenn jeder mit seinem buch sich in
die ecke zieht das ist ja eigentlich der
vorwurf den wir heute machen jeder hat
nur noch sein handy
deshalb kann man da eigentlich nicht
vorsichtig genug sein es ist glaube ich
richtig in der geschichte in dieser
beschleunigungs geschichte haben
menschen sich immer wieder an neuer
geschwindigkeiten eingebaut angepasst
und zwar erfolgreich in allem würde ich
in hinsicht in kommunikationstechniken
und praktiken und den verkehrstechnik
und praktiken und so weiter aber ich
finde nicht dass man deshalb die frage
beenden muss ob es vielleicht ein zu
viel an geschwindigkeit geben könnte ob
die uns weg läuft und dann muss man
fragen zu viel für bass und da glaube
ich kommt die frage in die zentrale
frage ins spiel zuviel für ein gutes
leben also wann gelingt menschliches
leben und zu viel für die art
politischer selbststeuerung die wir
gewählt haben nämlich so was wie
demokratie teilen sie grundsätzlich
seine sorge dass jetzt zu viel spielt
schon im system drin ist ja doch
die die sorge teil ich auf jeden fall
ich teile auch teile auch dede ist das
ein nostalgisches zurücksehnen auch
nicht hilft ja aber was was was helfen
könnte oder oder was man auch an sich
selber bemerken kann was man besser
machen kann ist bei der all den dingen
die man macht oder in die man verwickelt
ist darauf zu achten jedes braucht
eigentlich eine zeit um gut gemacht zu
werden
das finde ich so wichtig nicht herrn
taschenbier hat das dass die zeit die
etwas braucht ja dass die auch dass man
sich die aufnimmt aber ja aber da also
da ich wie ich bin auf einer seite ganz
bei ihnen ich frage mich nur wer der
mann ist also dass man sozusagen weil
ich glaube aber das hat auch nicht in
der hand weil ich glaube wirklich wenn
sie weil ich bin nun mal soziologe wenn
sie sich die arbeitswelt anschauen da
sehen sie genau dieses problem dass
nämlich selbst einfache arbeiter selbst
am fließband oder bei mcdonald's sagen
es gibt sozusagen ein richtiges maß dass
die sache gut machen und genau da wird
permanent daran gedreht mit dem versuch
man hat die zeit nicht
das gilt sowohl für so für genau
geregelte prozesse als auch für burkhard
was ich damit meine ist ja wenn wir nach
einem kriterien suchen ja dann ist das
für mich ein kriterium auf die zu tun
die sache auf die tätigkeit selbst hin
zu blicken und aus ihr selbst ein
kriterium zu gewinnen da leute so wird
es schlecht
es muss mindestens klar dass es ein das
ist auch ein politischer machtkampf
es ist wir sehen gerade bei vw
eigentliche also ich bin sozusagen der
druck so groß dass man die sache nicht
mehr gutmachen kann ja unter den kosten
oder anderen druckte steht dann fängt
man eine verletzung der gesetze dann
fängt man an zu tricksen oder so in
allerlei hinsichten und ich glaube dass
das sehen wir wirklich in ganz vielen
gesellschaftsbereichen und übrigens auch
weil sie sagten es kommt auf den
richtigen takt an das finde ich auch
also zum einer seine sache gut machen
gehört auch danach einen moment
innezuhalten und der pause zu haben
wir sehen dass wir systematisch zum
beispiel schon unseren jungen leuten den
jugend
diese pausen formieren sie müssen immer
schon bevor sie einen abschluss haben
wissen was sie danach machen schon mal
bewerbungen schreiben schon mal planen
die lehrenden oder die die schulberater
sagen den ihr seid zu spät dran wenn ihr
wartet bis er die matura habt also oder
das abitur um zu wissen was sie danach
macht während bachelor heute macht muss
schon wissen wir dann den maßnahmen
abwehren master macht muss bevor er den
abschluss hat schon die promotion skizze
eingereicht haben und dieses dinge nicht
mehr reifen zu lassen ist nicht etwas
was man in der eigenen verantwortung
hätte sondern was die gesellschaftlichen
strukturen sind und sie waren ziemlich
großes geschütze auf terminologie sagen
nicht nur das schlecht und sie sollten
wissen wir spielraum geben den jungen
sie sagen das ist total die tourismus
das quasi ein unsichtbares gespenst das
uns hier manipuliert
natürlich ist dieser begriff provokativ
gemeint und es ist wichtig zu sagen ist
nicht ein politischer totalitarismus aus
etwas anderes als die totalitarismen die
wir in der politischen geschichte kennen
aber es ist insofern totalitär als
erstes alle gesellschaftsschichten
ergreift es ist nicht so dass die so die
die also sagen wir mal arbeitslose
menschen oder kranke oder oder
vielleicht menschen im ruhestand davon
befreit werden auf die die sind
vielleicht zwangs entschleunigen
geradezu still gestellt aber die leiden
natürlich auch unter diesen
beschleunigungs druck weil sie dann
nicht mehr begründen weil sie schon
abgehängt sind und in allen anderen
lebensbereichen wird sich vielleicht
unterschiedlich aus menschen in
einfacheren berufen die haben den druck
meistens von außen menschen in der elite
positionen machen sich der druck von
innen aber es geht ist ergreift alle
schichten und alle lebensbereiche ist
immer findet diese beschleunigungs logik
in der arbeit im konsum sogar in
religiösen tätigkeiten in
freundschaftsbeziehungen in
familienbeziehungen es ist per brief in
der gesellschaft sie nennen das
entfremdung und damit als soziologe
holen sie da nicht einen bärtigen mann
mit zerzausten haar der in london
revolution betrieb einen karl marx
wieder aus dem schrank
naja gut also ich hätte jetzt keine
angst davor also viele der einsichten
von marx gerade darüber wie wie
kapitalismus funktioniert ja viel mehr
als dass da vielleicht kommunismus sein
könnte diese ansichten sind auch heute
noch sehr sehr hilfreich aber es stimmt
schon der in fremdes begriff ist in den
späten 60er 70er jahren hatte der
konjunktur und dann ist er in
vergessenheit geraten und ich glaube
dass das ein fehler ist es geht nicht
nur um verteilungen und
verteilungsgerechtigkeit obwohl die
wichtig sind sondern es geht auch um die
frage wann gelingt leben überhaupt
individuell und kollektiv
und dafür war diese befremdung sun
entfremdung analyse glaube ich ganz
hilfreich das problem war dass wir nicht
wussten nicht angeben konnte was nicht
in fremde das leben ist dafür sollte man
immer begriffe wie die wahre natur des
menschen ins spiel bringen oder
authentizität und philosophisch lassen
sich diese beiden beiden vorstellungen
ganz schlecht rechtfertigen und deshalb
arbeite ich gerade an einem neuen buch
das den titel resonanz trägt und
versucht zu sagen nein und da kommt das
was sie gerade sagt man auch ins spiel
also gelingende verhältnisse welt
verhältnisse sind wir eher welt
verhältnisse die die in resonanz mit der
arbeit mit anderen menschen mit der
natur gelebt werden können in einer art
von antwort verhältnisse und darüber
kann man glaube ich die richtigen zeit
maße vielleicht wiederfinden komme auf
die resonanz gerne nach glaube in ihrem
buch aber identifiziert zu haben immer
noch eine idee des wahren bewusstseins
ein weil sie schreiben irgendwo die
leute die dann über stresst sind und so
viele e mails haben und all das die
suchen dann eher glück in den shopping
malls und schauen noch in die glotze und
so ist das nicht ein bisschen die diese
konsumenten
falsch bewusstseins befriedigung und so
ist das nicht so einfach meine einer
gern kern dem shopping zentrum sein
glück findet warum nicht genau da habe
ich überhaupt keine einwände dagegen das
stimmt schon das sieht immer so nach
dieser alten konservativen kulturkritik
aus die eigentlich keiner mehr hören
will auch mit guten gründen werden will
aber ich finde ob dieser hinweis schon
reicht um zu sagen wir dürfen gar nicht
mehr ins kulturelle praktiken angucken
und da will ich nicht schreiben über die
dummen menschen dies falsch machen und
ich weiß es besser so zu sagen sondern
ich kann ich betrachte mich auch selber
und dann stelle ich fest da zieht mich
was in die shopping-mall da ist eine
attraktivität auch in kaufen der kauf
auch selber macht spaß
und dann stellt zum beispiel fest ich
wähle ich bin großer cd käufer also ich
mal das ist einer meiner lieblings
hobbys ich will eine cd kaufen und dann
stelle ich fest und die habe ich ja
schon so als müsste man auch ökonomische
logik sagen gut für mich ja ich kann das
geld sparen und habe die cd schon aber
da ist stelle ich fest als eine
enttäuschung im spiel und das ist und
ich finde es jetzt so langsam fahren mit
einem nachmittag ja wieso bin ich jetzt
eigentlich enttäuscht und dann stelle
ich fest okay es gibt da
verhaltensweisen sozusagen die die mich
erstmal irritieren und wo ich glaube
vielleicht ist ein falsches bewusstsein
insofern als man wenn man sie wenn man
sich auch selbst beobachtet bei welchen
aktivitäten bei welchen erfahrungen
sozusagen stellt sich hinterher
vielleicht ein bleibendes oder
dauerhaftes glücksgefühl ein und bei
welchen ist man eher in den zustand der
lehre oder eben der entfremdung so dass
man auch in sucht förmige
verhaltensweisen kommt also ich glaube
aber selbst analysen kommen wir viel
weiter als über so ideen dass wir schon
dass wahrer bewusstsein haben und die
anderen nicht ja aber es gibt doch auch
dieses jetzt weil beim konsum und bei
den produkten waren dass man natürlich
mehr und mehr feststellt dass die den
produkten ein produziert der
sterblichkeit um mehr zunimmt das hat
die gebe gehen aber schneller kaputt ja
meine dadurch also bye bye bye computer
ist doch ganz ganz deutlich wenn wenn
wenn ein kaputtes nach zwei jahren der
gucken sein doch schon ganz schräg an ja
da sind dass man da noch etwas in
reparatur
ich finde solche das sind ja nicht so
belanglose erfahrungen die man die macht
in diesem ganzen bereich der modernen
technologie auch beim handy usw
die sind einmal kaputt sind sie richtig
kann ja und das gibt einem schon so
dieses gefühl dass man sich in auch in
einer wahren welt befindet die deren
verlässlichkeit immer mehr nachlässt
sang deren eben und also wo man nicht
mehr emotional stabil darauf reagieren
kann auch deswegen ist jetzt wiederum vw
ist das natürlich auch ein wunderbares
beispiel dass das durch systematischer
betrug mit eingebaut das ja so wird
systematisch eingebaut dass die dinge
möglichst bald kaputt gehen damit man
neue produkt daran kommt in der summe
wenn die erfahrungen die man dann in der
warenwelt macht in der wahren welt in
der wir uns auch gerne aufhalten ja dann
darf man nicht heuchlerisch sein aber
manchmal kommt einem auch beck ich so
vor dass sich auch aus dieser welt die
verlässlichkeit und stabilität auch
zurückzieht und das das nimmt immer mehr
also also beschleicht einen der gefühle
bei der werbung hat man sowieso das
gefühl dass man umgeben ist von
verlogenheit
das ist ja so umgeben ist natürlich
nicht schön aber ist es nicht irgendwie
auch die grundidee des kapitalismus wie
schon peter dann gesagt hat eine
kreative zerstörung die kids im silicon
valley haben halten neuen irgendwas und
dass vielleicht die neuen generation
finde das ganz toll diesen ja aber das
tun sie ja nicht wirklich also ich meine
es ist was ambivalenz die man immer
sieht man geht zwar gerne aufs neue zu
wie sie es beschrieben haben sie es
schon seit der eisenbahn soll also
einerseits umarmt und milz haben auf der
anderen seite gibt es auch nicht
bestimmte skepsis und ich war übrigens
der bärtige alte mann karl marx hat
dafür schon interessanten begriff
gefunden wenn gleich als er auf die
produktion sphäre angewandt hat jetzt
haben das in der konsums fehler nämlich
dass der moralische verschleiß höher sei
als der physische das heißt wir werfen
die dinge ja in aller regel nicht weg
weil sie nicht mehr
funktionieren sondern weil sie schon
überholt sind weil sie veraltet sind und
der witz ist jetzt so komme ich auf die
entfremdung wir werfen sie eigentlich
weg gerade aber sowas wie handy ist es
so aber bei fast allen modernen computer
auch bei all diesen geräten wie haben
sie uns gar nie wirklich zu eigen
gemacht gar nicht wirklich an verwandeln
wir sind gar nicht dazu gekommen sie zu
unserem eigenen ding zu machen dass wir
das sind irgendwie sowas ein teil von
uns ist also weiß nicht wie mein
lieblings kurzwellenradio den ich
tatsächlich sehen und journalist jahren
immer bei mir hat deren begleiter jahren
hat er dann auch rumbasteln manipuliert
man und dann erkennen das ist wirklich
der eigene da ist was von mir da
eingegangen und was von neben mich und
so und diese art von anverwandlung
findet heute nicht mehr statt das ist
alles nicht schön aber ich glaube bei
beiden gedankengängen von ihnen zu
diesem thema wäre es dann richtig
tragisch wenn wir sagen die demokratie
ist in gefahr die bräuchte ein
langsameres tempo
naja ich meine die dass die demokratie
überhaupt meine geschwindigkeit hat das
ist ja schon mal wichtig festzuhalten
und das andere gesellschaftliche
bereiche andere geschwindigkeiten haben
also demokratie braucht da ja da muss
entschieden werden und da muss
nachgedacht werden ja nehmen sie das
beispiel in deutschland bei einem der
der rettungsschirme da musste das
bundesverfassungsgericht darüber nun
befinden ob das mit der verfassung
übereinstimmen und die finanzmärkte
haben schon mit den füßen gescharrt ja
und das bundesverfassungsgericht hatte
den stolz zu sagen wir brauchen vier
monate um das richtig herauszufinden und
da merken die doch das sind da sind zwei
geschwindigkeiten und wir haben da
natürlich auch haben da eigentlich dann
auch einen politischen machtkampf
welche geschwindigkeit soll denn nun
maßgeblich sein weil er hat angst dass
die finanzwelt gewinnt die zwingt der
demokratie ihr tempo einfach auf das
ihre sorge ja das kommt dann zu einer
aushöhlung von der demokratie also ich
glaube zu den großen von den grund
versprechen der moderne da gibts sowas
wie eine verheißung die mit der
fortschritt auch verknüpft dass das ist
ja nicht nur eine technische idee ist
die der selbstbestimmung dass die welt
der wir leben die strukturen in denen
wir uns bewegen in denen wir arbeiten
und handeln selbst bestimmt sind und es
geht ein politischer nicht neuen modus
der demokratie die schweiz ist er ja
auch ein sehr interessantes beispiel
dafür lebenswelt demokratisch zu
gestalten
und tatsächlich er hat demokratie eine
eigene zeit und ich glaube nicht nur
dass demokratie von natur aus relativ
langsam ist weil sie
entscheidungsfindungen und
meinungsbildung eben nicht per
durchsetzung feld sondern da muss werden
positionen formuliert werden argumente
ausgetauscht ist finden delegations
prozess statt und dann kommt es zu einer
entscheidungen in der schweiz kann man
tatsächlich diese ganzen stufen ja sehen
in der der direkten demokratie und vor
ein paar jahren gab es einen
beschleunigungs initiative sogenannte
data initiative ist damals noch
abgelehnt worden
die genau dieses argument machte habe
wir können entweder weiter so operieren
dann sind die entscheidungen die man
schon anachronistisch bis wir sechs
jahre später auf ein problem reagiert
haben ist es nicht mehr da oder wir
sorgen dafür dass demokratie nicht mehr
der schrittmacher des dienstes
gestaltende instrument für unsere wälder
sondern hinterherhinken nur noch feuer
löscht wie bei den flüchtlingen oder bei
den finanzmärkten wir kommen halt immer
zu spät mit dem was wir machen und das
untergräbt die demokratie und führt zu
dem was der kollege controls
postdemokratie nennt was tun partei eine
partei gründen die für zeitsouveränität
kämpft gibt übrigens naja bin ich als
als partei und wie gesagt war ein
auftritt aber es gibt so einen schönen
verein ja oder auch sogar mehrere eine
blockade mit sitz in der schweiz wo es
also um die vernünftige bewirtschaftung
der zeit geht und so weiter also das
erfüllt mich doch auch mit einiger
freude dass da dass da überhaupt eine
sensibilität für die das problem jetzt
langsam entsteht wie vor ein paar jahren
noch vor zehn fünfzehn jahren würde ich
mal sagen war im allgemeinen bewusstsein
dass überhaupt nicht drin
das gesellschaft etwas ist wo
verschiedene bereiche verschiedene
geschwindigkeiten haben und dass das ein
problem da einen lernprozess im gang
das ist wirklich das ist immer toll dass
das überhaupt ein problembewusstsein da
entsteht über den kasus ja ich gebe
ihnen völlig zu da gibt es tatsächlich
auf eine deutsche gesellschaft für
zeitpolitik verein zur verzögerung
derzeit die bringen das thema aufs tapet
und es gibt inzwischen viele parteien
die sich zu eigen machen ich habe nur
ein
sorge dabei dass man nämlich zeit als
ein isolierten faktor begreift jetzt
müssen wir zeit politik machen sowie der
wirtschafts oder bildungs und
familienpolitik oder arbeitspolitik
machen und ich glaube das ist falsch
weil die zeit quer läuft ja die zeit ist
in den wirtschaftsstrukturen in den
arbeits und produktionsstrukturen und in
der bildung jetzt hat muss man kann
nicht alles so lassen wie es ist und nur
die zeit verändern ich glaube wir
brauchen insgesamt überwindung dieser
steigerungs orientierung ich würde aber
trotzdem sagen es sind etwa so ein
vorgang also dass die natur zum thema
der politik gemacht wird ja das ist ja
auch relativ neu und dass sich das so
richtig durchgesetzt hat und zwar auch
der natur aspekt quer durch alle
gesellschaftlichen bereiche was aussteht
ist das so hat ähnliches auch in bezug
auf die bewirtschaftung der zeit dass so
was auch geschieht ja auch bei uns
verrinnt die zeit selbst in einer so
schönen langen einstündigen sendungen
noch so zehn minuten haben wir die hier
verriegeln dürfen
darum will ich vom gesellschaftlichen
noch einmal zurück auf grundsätzlich
philosophische kommen sie sagen in ihrem
buch bringen den hämischen begriff die
furie des verschwindens bedroht uns auf
ganz grausame weise immer und meine
schluss fragen gehen in die richtung wie
kann man an dieser furie entschwinden an
schönen satz habe ich gefunden wir sind
augenblicks wesen doch wir können uns in
ungeheure zeiträume hinaus denken wir
haben die möglichkeiten auch jetzt wenn
die gesellschaft rast und so da das ist
eine der großen fähigkeit dass wir
unsere geschichten das leben als reise
jeder sein eigener autos saß
das ist ein weg sich dafür zu entwinden
naja eben eine frühe für das
verschwinden man ein wunderbarer
ausdruck die dich fand von hegel da
übernehme und beziehe auf die auf einem
und der alltägliche erfahrung werde mit
der wir müssen wir alle umgehen wir es
ist vergangenheit das und es gibt
aspekte der vergangenheit die sind
unwiderruflich vorbei
die vorbei sind ja das ist das betrifft
zum beispiel unsere ganzen was wir so
nennen unsere inneren zustände die
äußeren zeichen der inneren zu stehen
wenn ich jetzt im brief geschrieben habe
oder oder oder ein lied dabei gesungen
habe oder irgend einem brief zerrissen
habe oder irgendetwas alle diese äußeren
manifestation auch die zeichen bleiben
bestehen aber der entsprechende innere
zustand ich wenn er mal vergangen mit
ganz vergangen und ich kann nie wissen
ob er
ob ich ob ich ihn wieder erwischt weil
mir das original spielt um zu sagen ja
das ist diesem moment das heißt das ist
natürlich nichts anderes als dass wir da
in dem wir bewusst zeit fahren immer
bemerken wie die wirklichkeit aus der
wirklichkeit verschwindet nämlich die
jetzt wirklichkeit wird zu einer
vergangenheit die nicht mehr wirklich
gegenwehr aber sicher schriftsteller
wenn es uns dann nieder schreibt ja aber
hier habe das sind die zeichen aber ich
weiß diesen zustand den ich hab was
aufgeschrieben von einem jahr vor zehn
jahren vor 20 jahren
ich kann den möglichen zustand der
dahinter ist den kann ich rekonstruieren
ich kann nie entscheiden ob es der ist
also das ist wirklich vorbei das ist das
ist diese das ist natürlich die dass
eine alltägliche erfahrung der der der
vergänglichkeit erklärt die erklärt
allerdings dass wir das dauert das das
verrinnen innerlich dauernd spüren ja
das erklärt natürlich weswegen wir auch
werden sind die so den äußeren halt
brauchen der auch die vergesellschaftet
zeit brauchen da die zeit der uhren das
doch wunderbar sein sohn auf seiner
ersten hat sich in kallenhardt manchmal
so das bild das bild alles sind raus die
fassade bleibt so das ist natürlich auch
die erfahrung der 2 wie gehen sie mit
der furie des verschwindens um ich also
in vertreten ist es ist eine schwierige
frage die ja sozusagen die existenzielle
vorwärts also die frage wie wir es mit
der zeit halten ist die frage wie wir
wie wär s mit unserem leben halten aber
ich glaube ich würde ein ganz klein
bisschen widersprechen wollen weil es
gibt momente in denen dieses vergangene
lebendig wird wir hatten ja schon marcel
proust in der berühmten madeleine szene
war dieses gebäck in lindenblütentee
taucht da beschreibt er das ist eine
sehr tolle literarische szene wie da
plötzlich ganze tiefen schichten in ihm
lebendig werden beschreibt das da kommt
etwas in bewegung und plötzlich stellt
sich eine verbindung her zu seiner
vergangenheit als kindheit wo immer im
haus seiner großmutter war das in diesem
fall auch das schon mal ecke gegessen
hatte solche momente nicht resonanz
momente weil das problem in dem was sie
beschreiben wir ja eine wahnsinnige
fragmentierung also die momente so zu
sagen es gibt jeweils nur jetzt momente
die in der nächsten zeit schon kann
bestand mehr haben und in der
vergangenheit nicht mehr auffindbar sind
und aber manchmal stellt sich in unserem
erleben und erfahren plötzlich eine
verbindung her
deshalb glaube ich die gelingende
momente des lebens sind gar nicht die wo
wir ausschließlich im hier und jetzt
sind sondern wo wir präsent sind im hier
und jetzt aber muss eine art von coop
präsenz und das nachklingen er ist noch
das gibt einen weg zurück und es ist
conchita falsches gibt er sagt es gibt
einen weg zurück ja ich meine den posten
wieder mal zitiere ich dem prüft auch
und das stimmt ja auch was was oder
jetzt hier beschreibt nur muss man noch
wie soll man sagen also man muss
trotzdem sagen dieses déjà vu dass dann
die das gefühl jetzt ist man altes ich
wiedergekehrt das ist natürlich ein
gefühl dass ich jetzt haben kann und das
ist auch was schönes los ich kenne ich
kann es prinzipiell nicht wissen ob es
wirklich das ist ja weil mir
gewissermaßen das original fehlt
tatsächlich an dem ich sagen kann ja das
ist doch genauso wie damals nein es ist
jetzt jetzt so wie damals aber das
damals ist nicht da
das meine ich dieses dieses und das ist
ja ein mehrschichtiger vorgang also ich
will da ja also werde ich dieses
vergehen beschreibe dann versuche aber
auch zugleich zu beschreiben
diese unter diesen ungeheuren vorgang
dass wir aber das gefühl haben
wir sind können in die vergangenheit
eintauchen
wir können in die zukunft blicken ja das
heißt wir sind auf einer bestimmten
ebene sind wir wieder auch mit großer
emotionalität können wir herumfuhrwerken
in dem ganzen zeit kosmos wir können mit
mit mirja millionen rechnen das tun wir
locker reden wir über den urknall und
reden über die implosion am ende usw
da sind haben wir so eine eigenartige
virtuelle zeitsouveränität aber ganz eng
gesehen ist so existenziell zeit rinnt
aus und so was ist nicht richtig schlimm
dass selbst wenn wir diese tollen reisen
in jahrmilliarden machen können das
können wir nur solange wir hier sind wir
physisch biologisch hier sind und wir
wissen und sie zitieren den satz von
nietzsche war sagt kluges tier im
weltall hat das erkennen erfunden und
irgendwann wird alles erlöschen
und dann sind ja nicht mehr da das ist
doch dann unerträglich sich sich selber
da wieder raus zu denken leiten sie da
auch ein bisschen darunter
ich finde nicht so also ich glaube
ehrlich gesagt der tod ist insbesondere
dann schlimm wenn man sich wirklich als
als nicht resonant versteht als
atomisiert und dieses atom wird
verschwinden das ist richtig und ich
glaube schon dass es dann eben
verschiedene strategien gibt damit
umzugehen marianne gronemeyer hat ein
tolles buch geschrieben das leben als
letzte gelegenheit wenn sozusagen diese
ewigkeit hoffnung verschwinden dann
bleibt nur noch das diesseits also wer
also eine strategie dazu sagen der tod
ist nicht das ende das geht irgendwie
weiter oder ich werde wieder geboren
oder so eine andere idee ist zu sagen
habe eine spur von mir lebt weiter
vielleicht ein werk vielleicht ein kind
vielleicht sonst etwas aber ich glaube
wenn wir unsere in der welt sein als ein
reh so nantes existenz weise verstehen
eines das in verbindung ist mit vielen
anderen dingen dann bleibt sozusagen
dieses dieses gesamt moment dieses
bewegungs moment ja erhalten dann ist es
isolierte atomisierten sterben von euch
gar nicht so kritiker safranski bitte
retten sie die idee der ewigkeit hier
als ich ihr buch gelesen habe habe ich
gedacht sie haben recht wenn sie
schreiben wir können uns er kann ist
aber ich abgesagt
wegdenken das ist ein 1 1 zu
schauderhafte gedanke die dieser dieser
hunger nach ewigkeit
naja der hunger nach ewigkeit wäre ja
nicht da wenn wenn wenn ewigkeit
wirklich nur eine unendliche zeit wäre
jemanden dass da kommt ja eher
langweilig da möchten sie auch mal ein
nein es ist immer schon in der
menschheitsgeschichte würde ich mal
sagen ewigkeit als terminus verstanden
warum etwas anderes als die zeit eben
nicht eine unendlich verlängerte zeit
sondern etwas anderes als die zeit und
da
da kann man natürlich fest stellen nicht
natürlich aber wenn man darauf achtet da
sind auch sogar unsere
alltagserfahrungen voll davon in jedem
akt der hingabe wenn man sich selbst und
und und alles vergisst und nur dass das
macht oder im auge hat oder spürt womit
man gerade befasst ist ja das eine
hingabe es zb ein ein gefühl der
überwindung der zeit in der zeit ja das
ist dann macht man nur einmal denkbar
hoppla mein gott wird die zeit ist
vergangen die war ganz ganz weg da man
ist in der zeit geblieben aber man ist
dieser art von mächtigkeit diesen tick
tack der zeit dass man entflohen
für diesen moment und macht ihnen dann
ich komme wieder mit nach 27 hervor
geholt haben und ich bin gar nicht
dagegen dass nicht mehr sorge wie marx
gesagt hat der harte sieg da gattungen
über das individuum ich als individuum
bin da nicht mehr da das stecken sie weg
lade ich war ich weiß ich will da der
frage würde ich mich eigentlich lieber
agnostisch verhalten also als soziologe
kann ich sie sowieso nicht beantworten
ich glaube wirklich ich finde also wenn
ich sozusagen emotional darauf reagieren
sollte finde ich die idee dass es da
eine art von existenzform so etwas wie
den weltgeist gibt auch eine art von
hegeler idee mit dem man verbunden ist
und in dem man vielleicht zurückkehrt
das finde ich eine sehr plausible idee
wie gesagt ich möchte eigentlich weg von
einer betrachtung die sie also ich
möchte in die video und gattung gar
nicht so kalt gegeneinander stellen
ich glaube dass wir auch als individuen
ja immer schon verbunden sind mit
anderen menschen aber auch mit der natur
und mit der zeit und der ewigkeit ja wir
sind nicht diese atomisierten individuen
schlussfrage der glückliche frei
schwebende schriftsteller safranski wie
sieht der das mit dem individuum und wie
sehr hoffte er dass darauf dass meine
bücher mich überleben ja das ist etwas
großartiges wenn ich auch jetzt bücher
von toten autoren autorinnen
das ist doch ein unglaubliches die leben
ja noch wer in dem man sie liest die
leben doch das ist doch in meiner mutter
so alltäglich aber also so wunderbar und
das wenn das bei meinem bücher wenn da
wenn die mich überleben dann bin ich
schon mal ist mein ewigkeit bedarf an
dem punkt schon mal vielleicht nicht
gedeckt aber doch ein stück weit
befriedigt ja das freut sie auch wenn
ihre bücher noch gelesen werden ist das
schlimmste was passieren kann sowie die
geschrieben sind habe ich keine zweifel
daran meine herren
besten dank für das gespräch ja und wie
wir der frage des tores und dem ewigen
sein oder nichtsein dann entgegen
schauen das hängt natürlich auch damit
zusammen wie wir es mit der religion
halten und diese gretchenfrage packt
meine kollegin barbara bleisch in einer
woche hier frontal an
die meisten philosophen heute sind eher
atheisten nicht so der berliner
wissenschaftstheoretiker und philosoph
holm tettens der den gottesglauben für
sich neu entdeckt hat sein kollege
philipp übel findet allerdings dafür
gäbe es keinen guten konter dies punkte
über die gretchen-frage in acht tagen in
diesem studio und wie wir sie in dieser
frage stehen ich wünsche ihnen jetzt ein
ganz wundervoller sonntag
[Musik]